wir bleiben beim thema putin und kommen
noch zu einem thema was mir heute abend
sehr wichtig ist uns war dass putin
nicht russland ist die wut über putins
angriffskrieg ist groß in deutschland
merkt auch hier in der runde doch sie
verwandelt sich fälschlicherweise auch
in zorn auf unbeteiligte nachbarn mit
studenten und russische restaurants als
sei jeder mit russischem hintergrund
putin fan das darf nicht sein was mich
besonders schockiert eine mail über die
zuerst die zeit berichtete die
direktorin der universitätsklinik
münchen schrieb zitat aufgrund der
schweren völkerrechts verletzung durch
den offenbar geistig gestört autokraten
putin bis hierhin stimme noch zu jetzt
nicht mehr legen wir ab sofort
grundsätzlich die behandlung russischer
patienten ab ukrainische patient sind
natürlich herzlich willkommen sie hatte
diese mail an eine beraterin verschickt
über umwege landete diese dann auf
facebook auf anfrage von zeit online
teilte das krankenhaus dann mit dass es
sich keineswegs um ein offizielles
statement der klinik handel die
absenderin hat in einer sehr emotionalen
situation ihre persönliche meinung
mitgeteilt dies aber inzwischen bereits
bedauert ich sage es nicht gern und ich
sage das nicht oft aber es sind schon
menschen für weniger zurückgetrieben als
für sowas und es ist nur ein symbol für
das was in deutschland los auch wenn ich
viele nach acht redaktion haben sich den
letzten tagen großen gewarnt die in
deutschland leben und gebeten dass wir
uns hier in der runde für sie einsetzen
das möchte ich hiermit gerne tun putin
ist nicht russland hass auf alles was
russisch ist darf nicht die antwort auf
putins krieg seien ich bin nicht die
einzige es heute anspricht herz sie
haben heute auch in der union mario
czaja der amtierende generalsekretär
heute auch ein statement abgegeben
deswegen würde ich direkt zu ihm
übergeben mit der these ja ich halte das
auch ganz ausdrücklich mario czaja das
gemacht heute in dem statement wie fand
richtig und klar und deutlich so sich
merz hat einen offenen brief geschrieben
auch an die unter russlanddeutschen
das ist dürfen diesen politischen
konflikt diesen krieg von putin nicht zu
einem teil unserer gesellschaft werden
lassen wo menschen ausgetreten ist
werden weil sie eine herkunft haben wie
zb die russische und ehrlicher weise
können wir darauf stolz sein was wir in
deutschland haben wissen sie in dem
hochhaus in dem ich groß geworden bin da
gab es im prinzip drei gruppen das waren
russen und ukrainer und polen im laufe
der jahre wir haben zusammen als kinder
gespielt später als wir etwas älter
waren haben wir zusammen auch was
gegessen und
einmal kurz
war mit dem essen das hätten sie mir
nicht abgekauft und so haben wir denn
wir sind in einem danken wir kennen uns
bis heute und deswegen sage ich teile
das ganz ausdrücklich dass es putins
krieg und dass die russlanddeutschen
carina die von dort gekommen sind das
sind deutsche staatsangehörige häufig
und insofern sage ich wir sind eine
gesellschaft und deswegen keine
diskriminierung
paris die lage in kiew wenn du dort mit
den menschen spricht natürlich auch über
russland ist es dort auch dass man auch
feststellt was in der situation ehrlich
sagen anders als in deutschland ein
stückweit verständlicher ist dass der
hass auf alles russische groß ist oder
es anders als hier in deutschland
nein es ist natürlich sehr viel
intensiver als in deutschland aber man
muss sich das mal vorstellen ich meine
ist es ja nicht so dass nur wladimir
putin hier in einem panzer steht und die
ukraine angreift sondern eben hundert
tausende russische soldaten
ich stimme dem zu was er gesagt hat
natürlich gerade darf es nicht zu diesen
vorfällen kommen ist für mich eine
selbstverständlichkeit
dass das nicht passieren darf und
dagegen müssen uns alle werden und
dennoch muss ich sagen es ist eben nicht
nur putins krieg denn es gibt sehr viele
menschen die dafür gesorgt haben dass
wladimir putin präsident wurde er war ja
auch mal ein anderer präsident das
stimmt zwar er war beliebt und ist
beliebt es gibt viele menschen peter
tiede macht das immer wieder sehr
eindrucksvoll unserer reporter in
russland wenn er dort mit den menschen
spricht die kaufen ihm das alles ab dann
kann man sagen okay die sind jetzt
vielleicht alle brainwash durch diese
massen propaganda die es dort gibt wir
haben gerade gehört dass facebook jetzt
auch offiziell blockiert ist also
russland entwickelt sich momentan
richtung nordkorea aber dennoch hat
natürlich die russische gesellschaft
eine verantwortung dafür wer präsident
geworden ist und die russische
gesellschaft hat genauso eine
verantwortung dafür dass sie in diesem
moment als dieser krieg ausgebrochen ist
mit einer viel größeren anzahl von
menschen hätte demonstrieren müssen ich
weiß das ist alles leicht gesagt auch
aus der ukraine leicht gesagt als
reporter leicht gesagt der sich nicht
hiergegen die polizei stellen muss aber
ich würde mir wünschen und ich hätte
auch erwartet dass die zahl der
demonstranten gegen putin wesentlich
höher ist und wenn es einer sagen kann
paul bist du der sich jeden tag mit mut
in der ukraine in kiew auf fällt also
ich finde es einer sagen darf da du
darfst das verlangen an meinen augen
klasse sich um diese leite ich würde
diesen von paul fast ein bisschen
zaghaft ausgesprochen gedanken noch
verstärken wollen jeder der putin
gewählt hat hat anteil an diesem krieg
mitschuld an diesem krieg den putin hat
sich ja quasi nicht irgendwie besonders
verwandelt also er hat sein äußeres
ziemlich verändert wenn man das so sagen
darf
ob freiwillig oder aus krankheitsgründen
wird der heftig diskutiert aber es war
ja völlig klar dass es sich nicht um
einen lupenreinen demokraten handelt den
mann der welt als erste in deutschland
jedem klar dass
einer der unterirdischen setzte der
wahrscheinlich jemals gesagt wurde ja
gerhard schröder über wladimir putin und
da ist es ja auch immer schon so
eingeordnet worden und deswegen kann man
jetzt nicht per blanco scheint die
gesamte russische bevölkerung und
wählerschaft freisprechen es ist nur
diese eine verrückte mann und seine
seine oligarchen clique und ein paar
general ist sondern das ist schon
der führt da schon aus was viele russen
für richtig halten das muss man sich
schon klar machen aber jetzt umgekehrt
darf daraus auch nicht der schluss
gezogen werden alle müssen wollen die
volunteers platt machen im gegenteil da
da da da tickt in mir auch so was für
mich das ganze noch unvorstellbarer
macht also es gibt ganz viele
persönliche beziehungen in russischen
familien zur ukrainischen familien und
wahrscheinlich würde man bei den 150
tausend soldaten ganz viele kennen die
wenn sie auf kiew schießen auf ihre
cousine schießen oder auch in
entfernteren verwandten oder nahen
verwandten also das ist ja das ist ja
quasi
aus deutscher sicht fast nur zu
begreifen wenn man sich vorstellt dass
ich in der bundeswehr ausgebildet worden
bin um auf die nva zu schießen ja also
deutsche schießen auf deutsche das ist
dann noch die verrückte steigerung von
allem hier allerdings um die freiheit zu
verteidigen
und nicht sie abzuschaffen so und das
finde ich ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger
punkt bei dem urteil der russen die gibt
es halt nicht jetzt muss ich quasi
einen satz noch dazu sagen auch nicht
alle ukraine sind lupenreine demokraten
ja also auch da gilt es natürlich zu
unterscheiden nicht aber in dieser
stunde denn in dieser stunde kämpfen die
einen für die freiheit und die anderen
gegen die freiheit und dann hat man sich
als freiheitsliebender mensch nicht mehr
groß feind zu isolieren sondern dann
steht man auf der einen seite und gegen
die anderes hat ich werde auch eine ganz
kurze frage einer zehn jahre stellen ich
brauche nur eine ganz kurze antwort aber
leider waren kurz unterbrechen jetzt sie
merkt fanden sie heute die sanktionen
gegen die opernsängerin netrebko richtig
für den opernhäusern weltweit
das ist also in einer kurzen antwort ist
schwierig zu sagen ich finde das sind
diejenigen also ich würde mir mehr
sanktionen wünschen übrigens gegen
diejenigen die das geld hier auch in
europa haben diejenigen die den
westlichen luxus den lebensstil gerne
pflegen in demokratie
fühlen aber krieg mit ihrem geld
finanzieren